Selena Gomez tearful billboard speech
plus Kent James Corden outsmart BTS
happy Friday my peeps welcome back to
the daily Denny now after I showed you
guys those pics of Justin and Selena
yesterday Gomez was honored with the
Woman of the Year award by Billboard
magazine Selena tearfully accepted the
honor which was presented to her by the
woman who saved her life to be honest I
think Francie should be restored because
she saved my life
what does this mean to you especially
the trend after the transformation of
this year honestly I'm I'm very honored
I really am and I think right now
especially with everything going on in
my industry it's really it's empowering
to see the voice that women have right
now what is inspiring about her for you
everything I mean her generosity she's
just genuine and her hard hard work
honestly can I tell you like way she was
in the hospital labor she was in the
hospital and she had to shoot fetish and
she got out of the hospital literally
got out and what strained it to hair and
makeup to go finish shooting her work
ethic is like unbelievable where you are
constantly reinventing yourself but you
said this is you know you're full you're
feeling like yourself I feel like if
you're still there's not really a lot of
change and I'm I'm constantly somebody
that likes to grow and feel like alright
what could I be better at what could I
do better at where where could my
confidence be stronger in Billboard
magazine the 25 year old talks about her
relationship with Bieber saying maybe
before it could have been forcing
something that wasn't right but that
doesn't mean caring for someone ever
goes away I like to choose to live my
life in a way where I want to be wait
free and I know that's impossible to do
because I have a million on me right now
but I and everybody does but I think it
is important to kind of go through your
life the way you want and I like to come
at things with my best that's all I know
how to do it
just give my best that girl is so
inspiring but also COO talk about how
amazing she look last night we have
plenty more with Selena and Francia up
on our website ET online.com and tonight
on ET but switching gears now to Prince
Harry and Megan Marco you didn't think
I'd end the week without talking about
them again did you I'm becoming
borderline obsessed with these two and
they just made their first joint visit
since their engagement this couple I
swear looking they were not shy about
showing some PDA during their first
official appearance together at a World
AIDS Day charity fair
Harry couldn't keep his hands off his
bride-to-be and clearly the future
Duchess has won the hearts of England -
I think it's safe to say Megan is fully
embracing her new royal role but you
know who's adjusting to their Fame here
in America
my boys BTS the band performed on
Thursday's episode of James Corden but
before taking the stage they tried to
show just how brave and calm they really
are as James Pelton threw at them for a
game of flinch
[Applause]
I've watched that 12 times now according
to RM those two are the cowards of the
group but the person who managed to stay
cool was our man V alright guys before
we sign off it is the return of our
beloved new music Friday playlist and
how fitting because Ed Sheeran just
dropped a remix of a sappy love ballad
perfect with none other than Beyonce
[Music]
and
she
I don't
you look tonight song is beautiful I
want to dance to it at my wedding I'm
not engaged not even dating anyone ever
find love look away just listen to how
that song came together and the song
came out so long ago in the scheme of
like music now like music kind of goes
so fast and I was like I want to do it
as a single and then I thought of a way
of relaunching it and you know I was
like wow I I love Beyonce shall I ask
Beyonce and then in my head I was like
she's gonna say no and then I was like
well you might as well ask and she said
yeah Wow all right guys our next track
is a complete 180 it's about a strained
relationship and comes courtesy of
Martin garrix and David Guetta who
teamed up for so far away
so
[Music]
and I'm back alright guys finally it is
December 1st which means it's socially
acceptable to start bumping some
Christmas tunes and they're actually
some really dope offerings this holiday
season including see his new track
Santa's coming for us
[Music]
so there aren't a lot of lyrics to that
chorus but it's still a nice Yuletide
Bop alright that's it for today you guys
thanks for hanging with us all week long
we'll be back on Monday so be sure to
subscribe to our Channel and make sure
you guys save this playlist and have a
good weekend Santa's got a man bar I
sound just like SIA